[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute werden wir hier eine
faschingsparty veranstaltungen für groß
und klein mit dem team und ich möchte
euch heute einfach so ein bisschen
zeigen was ich vorbereitet und wie ihr
auch zu hause ganz einfach mit wenigen
mitteln und auch sehr kostengünstig ein
faschings pc oder ein party beheben
machen könnt was ich hier schon gemacht
habe ist zum einen haben papageien
kuchen gebacken das ist der bunte kuchen
vom blech da ist schon fertig da gibt es
auch ein eigenes video dazu und ich habe
noch die muffins in waffel bäcker
gebacken diese nämlich super handlich
richtig lecker vor allem könnte sie
dekorieren wie ihr wollt da gibt es auch
ein anderes video dazu und jetzt kommt
erstmal die herzhafte variante ich mache
jetzt nämlich noch würstchen im
schlafrock als mini portionen das sag
ich mal kurz die zutaten für den teig
für den hefeteig verwende ich 250 gramm
es war ein viertel würfel hefe etwas
zucker 450 gramm mehl einen teelöffel
salz etwas olivenöl und hier habe ich
noch ein paar würstchen
es ist nämlich jetzt die hefe mit dem
zucker kommt jetzt alles in die
rührschüssel die hefe zerbrechlich ein
bisschen da kommt das wasser mit dazu
kurz verrühren mit gebe ich erst mal ein
bisschen mehl dazu fangen an den teig
kneten und gibt dann einfach die
restlichen zutaten dazu sei es noch mit
rein und auch das öl und den teig jetzt
einfach für etwa fünf minuten kneten bis
so schön geschmeidig ist jetzt ist der
teig fertig den gebe ich jetzt in die
schüssel zurückdenken ab und lasse ihn
aufgeben und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich schon mal die würstchen sein
schneiden müssen wir jetzt einfach
umziehen muss ich jetzt wohl dass die
bühne nicht dabei ist die könige szene
die einen sagen ich wusste dass du ein
türkischer hütchenspieler bist so dass
sich der kreis wieder zurückschicken ok
damit der gerade voller koch debatte
denn also ich will jetzt keine namen
nennen aber die eigentlichen die kochte
er nämlich sorgt ja das wasser
aufgekocht und dann die hohen einreichen
wollte reinlegen
ich habe mir dann gedacht die platz und
doch dann also eier in kochendes wasser
und dann ist noch umständlicher weil ich
mache noch so ich lege die rohen eier in
den topf und dies dann wasser auf und
dann asis aufkochen zu verbrennen sich
nicht die finger die feier platzen nicht
auf wie kocht ihr zuhause eier in kaltes
wasser und dann auf kochen oder in
kochendes wasser
[Musik]
ich meine frau kocht meine eier deswegen
berater witz erzählen kann ich allein
erzählt ok und zwar folgendes warum
legen hühner eier
ja wenn sie sich meist werden sie kaputt
gehen jetzt habe ich noch uns war
folgendes die polizei klopft an der tür
ok und sagt aufmachen dann sagt der
hintertür
ich will keine eier er sagt da sagt die
polizei wir haben auch keine dann sagt
der typ ii natürlich weiß auch blöd okay
war frohe weihnachten ostern fasching
macht's gut
zu kaufen ist einfach ich bin es gab
eine zeit da habe ich mich morgens
mittags und abends von eiern ernährt hat
mein papa für mich gekocht als die mama
mal weg war
wie gehst du deine eier
[Musik]
anna ich dachte mir jeder macht so wie
ich das mache so kann egal ich schneide
jetzt mal dieser schlag das sind
übrigens die soz aus dem türkischen
supermarkt da gibt es da immer an der
frischetheke und die sind einfach echt
mega lecker die sind schon gut
[Musik]
der hilfreich ist aufgegangen und jetzt
kann ich den portionieren
ich habe 27 kleine würstchen waren
nämlich neun stück und die habe ich
einfach gedrittelt und samira du kannst
nebenher die götterspeise machen
wackelpudding und damit so ein instant
wackelpudding man kann es auch mit acker
machen instanz wackelpudding ist
übrigens auch ohne gelatine als auch
vegan und da muss jetzt einfach nur das
wasser kochen und dann damit verrühren
uns fertig
[Musik]
und wenn ihr dann diese kleinen portion
gehabt wollt ihr sie zu einem langen
strang und wickelt einfach herum
das kann man übrigens auch mit
blätterteig machen aber mir geschmeckt
mit sohn pizzateig meistens viel besser
[Musik]
machte es jetzt hier noch fertig dann
bestreite ich sie mit ei und bestreut
sie mit sesam dann können sie schon
gebacken werden und dann gehts noch an
unser gemüse buffet da machen wir
nämlich auch was richtig lustig ist okay
manchmal macht durch ja schon mal weiter
und macht einen wackelpudding und ich
mache das gemüsebeet
[Musik]
doch die iris werdet ins kalte wasser
geschmissen
keine ahnung was passiert wir machen
jetzt ein clown
wir feiern doch gleich fasching ach so
ja ok ein clown aus und gemüse ja okay
so rathmann was das wird der hut von
mira trips gleichfarbige okay also ich
habe mir da ist eine vorlage gemalt wenn
man so ein großes holzbrett vom alex aus
der werkstatt und jetzt probiere man das
einfach mal als ich glaube wenn man
jetzt hier in der mitte die tomate
nehmen ich habe ich zwei kleine
schälchen mit joghurt also könnte
einfach einen dip nehmen so steht schon
mal das grundgerüst und jetzt habe ich
hier radieschen die haben wir auch schon
sauber gemacht die linke hat und so als
fahre
denn dann haben wir auch noch ein
schönes gemüse buffet weil ich bin
gerade bei so einer faschingsfeier da
ist man immer gerne mal und es anders
viel schaumküsse und so weiter und dann
haben wir noch bissl was gesundes auf
dem tisch also das heißt die paprika die
schneiden wir in feine streifen
ich drückte man da oben so rein ganz
feine also so stifter von köln und dann
kann man den boden weg schneider und
dann die vier saiten
du hast eine blume geschnitten und ich
will wissen warum deine verflachen und
meinte hundt und jetzt wirklich warum
sind die gene also gebote weg und dann
123 punkten der stoff hier aber im zaun
geflogen sind auch schön auch voll schön
ja jetzt schon ein was ich einfach in
streifen in streifen so was von dir
samira genau braucht auf streifen für
die er ist müsste wissen ist voll der
faschings mensch
ich eigentlich auch nicht aber ich mache
gerne rezepte für euch sich verkleidet
das ganze jahr über
ja ja ja ich vergesse ich auch manchmal
nimmt die perücke und metalle bisserl
schnitzel arbeit aber guckt mal mit
freunden als hätte es gewusst ich seh
vorbei gekommen um mir beim schnippeln
zu helfen
was wird es was werden die kurven der
hut also im jahr kann man auch hin zur
scheibe lastete konzertplatz seine ruhig
so genau weil schwarz dann fange ich
vielleicht schon mal an da hin zu legen
oder aber mal was brauchen wir noch
karotten müssen wir noch ich glaube als
sticks hat das halt einfach nur kann man
die besser essen die kohlrabi der die
dass die kohlrabi kann man auch in so
sticks oder schreiben dürfen und was
darf weiter auf dem buffet nie fehlen
was hast du eigentlich immer so gern
wenn ihr so party also wenn wir also ich
liebe so gibt's knoblauch der bei waren
wir eigentlich immer zu hause immer
sonderlich bisschen gebackenes bisschen
rohkost immer bisschen süß bis herzhaft
genau wobei ich mir der herzhafte malte
petersen
als ich in mehr als ich nach waghäusel
gezogen werden damals vor vielen vielen
jahren
da hatte ich glück nun der dritten art
das war
fasching in baku ist in burgeis und
pokal
mein nachbar hat geklingelt und ich habe
gesteht spion geschaut und habe keine
ahnung was ist das und dann er ist noch
auf machst der harry von oben komplett
magazinen behangen mit pelzen heißt
harry was ist los ihr haupt macht die
tür auf meinem blog heute so wie ich mit
dir gegen schlumpf
das gibt es glaube ich auch noch bei uns
das wort da geht man halt so verkleidet
unterhaltung die häuser ja als kumpel
und es war früher ganz extrem da konnte
man wirklich nett auf die straße gehen
er war ausnahmezustand um die hier noch
die käsewürfel und dann legen wir jetzt
alles einfach dort drauf und dann
entsteht hier gleich ein clown gesicht
wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss ich hasse
clowns ich habe angst vor dem ich habe
bei unseren tipp die augen des todes 2
oliver sommer soll in demeter oder so
schön viel käse kann man jetzt ein
rundes gesicht
[Musik]
man kann sich der business for sap
ziehen aber ich glaube das passt
bei dir ich höre nicht auf deine tante
ihre drachen religion ja als
überraschung resort a-rosa brava das
ging aber schnell hat wehgetan aus super
eingestochen
dann haben jetzt paprika und radieschen
für die haare
ich geb dir mal die hälfte ich glaube
man erkennt schon und da war jetzt noch
ein coole hut so hat noch sogar so ein
farbverlauf der stadt dunkel hell und so
noch kann man schön käse mit traube
essen vor allem dunkle trauben lecker
und dann so karotten und die kohlrabi
genau einfach so als kragen
ja kann man so ein bisserl farbig gerne
weil ich habe streife
kennt ihr noch die art attack videos
derartige krisen bergriesen bild oh mein
gott was die philosophie der tenniswelt
fräsen bild kennt jetzt noch das artete
krisen sind jetzt aber jede verließ
verschließen will
cool oder denn somit einfach ganz
einfach schnell gemacht verhext ok ihres
du darfst du dir reden ja cool für das
sagen wir holen jetzt alles was wir
vorbereitet haben decken das buffet hol
unsere kostüme oder machen eine
faschingsparty frisch mit mir kannste
mir das alles macht das ding nicht
wegsackte bad nicht mehr zurückgeben
[Gelächter]
über den wolken muss die freiheit wohl
grenzenlos sein lieber gummi jahres soll
ich darf ich glaube dass er die
steilvorlage würdig gewesen für den
türkischen hütchenspieler wo ist das
blättchen wo ist das recht ja wie sehe
ich aus maxime ein kuss geben
[Musik]
der ist mir gewachsen ja das hat morgen
gewachsen es geht vorschnell wirst du
auch ein haben warum
aber jetzt ein kuss ein kleines nur
einen kleinen riss habe mich schön roce
von york mit
[Musik]
ein ganz normaler tag eben aus der
lebenswelt und es wird bald ist eine
feier wenn sie mutter durchdreht
übernimmt das kinderkanal ticks ab all
das ist meine welt
[Musik]
das buffet ist eröffnet ja oder was sagt
unsere mexikanischer paparazzi und wir
sind erst dabei jetzt haben sich handelt
ob also also dass kein surfen
was ist dir das rapper maxi kann wenn
ich meine mutter sieht ich bin nicht nur
ich bin der kleine bruder wieder anders
es gibt den weg kein recht die
schnellste maus von mexiko sind in
mexiko kaiser der bbc unsere probieren
oder darf ich noch eins fragen wird also
das objekt 1 fragen was ersten wagen ja
bitte
darf ich dir später den top 10 gewählt
also nein macht es nicht ich finde er
wie soll man essen kann ich ja aber das
ist ein partytier also machen wir jetzt
nicht alleine sondern party people are
people hinter geht das so einfach muss
ich sagen die vögel sind sie endlich
schade wäre hier ist der blick blamiere
kommt jetzt eine steirische schnitzel
hilfe in der kirche sorgt auf jeden fall
das ist party people die forscher
jeweils platz die hosen voll crs okay
dann steht der vulkan ist groß endlich
so richtig ihr ist er ist hast du mal am
normal stetig an
zu essen zu trinken die politiker die
kinder essen schon lieber gott sei dank
ist das ein alkoholfreier haushalt weil
die partypeople machen ja die techniker
schon rassig und 15 mal gemacht ja aber
hallo zu jeder party und wirst du im
schlafrock ich habe mein base
radieschen jetzt ruhig fast immer vorne
wir haben die partien sagt ich möchte
wie radieschen
früher hast du bei uns in unser geld ich
denke ich gesagt zwischen analog käse
passt da ist eine plastik da net von
gaza das entsprach also der mexikaner
ich kann ich essen mit dem bart die kann
man essen und dann hat mich mein bart
gehabt und gegessen
da macht man sowas da steht alles drin
und in zwei gehen auf tour liebe hipster
wenn ihr dazu schaut wie ist hier mit
dem watt und verstecken alles war
einfach kein chor der ist übrigens ganz
ganz bekannt im osten von deutschland
hat einen kurs machen weil er nach
schnecken die die kuchen schmeckt es dir
auf jeden waren die coole geschichte
ich mache das weiterkommen ein bisschen
musik musik musik und jetzt kannst du
okay und jetzt 126
[Musik]
mit baby oder machte mir viel spaß mit
eurem faschingsparty bequem bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]